- She's an American singer, songwriter,
actress, reality TV star,
and fashion designer.
She rose to fame with the
release of her debut single,
"I want to Love You Forever."
She's the founder of the
Jessica Simpson Collection,
a fashion line clothing that's
worth a billion dollars.
She's Jessica Simpson and
here are her top 10 rules
for success.
- We always take trips.
We'll go to Paris and we'll
do our inspiration shopping.
But I love to go into vintage stores.
I love to go into vintage record stores.
I'm inspired by art, music.
I love and appreciate
every person out there,
whether it be a musician or--
I have all these--
I collect vintage records.
So, I think album art is always
a cool way to be inspired
as well.
I think from other people's mistakes.
I mean, being in the
public eye for so long,
I've made a ton of mistakes
and everybody knows about them.
But I don't look at,
I look at my mistakes
and any sort of failure
that I have gone through
as a lesson to be learned.
And I work through it and success follows.
I truly remain inspired
by each and every woman
that I meet.
My mother is a huge part of my business.
She is my mentor throughout all of this.
She's been styling me since
I came out of the womb.
And I trust her with my business
and just being a part of it with her
and all of our design teams.
It's not just me, it's not just my ideas.
And I think that it's really
important to humble yourself
and really understand
that you would never have
the business that you have if
it weren't for all the people
that are helping you get there.
I feel like the most empowering lesson
that I have learned is,
failure is okay sometimes.
And in that we grow and we learn from that
and there's success around the corner.
And we have done so many different things
in growing this brand
and it just continues.
It continues to keep on keepin' on.
And we're just very, very blessed.
And when I say "we're," it's
not just me that is my brand.
There are so many people
that deserve the credit
for the Jessica Simpson Collection.
I've had flight attendants
come up to me and say,
"I have to wear Jessica
Simpson shoes because they're
the only ones that are
comfortable for me to stand
on the whole flight."
And I listened.
I think that that's important too.
Really just listening to your customer
and to the people that are
giving you the feedback.
Whether it's criticism or
honoring and being people like,
"Thank you so much!
I met the cutest guy last night because of
that dress that I wore."
(laughing)
You know, I listen to all of it.
It's okay to cry and
it's okay to feel upset
because there's always perseverance
and there's always success
and there's always a way to get back up
and make it happen again.
So, I think that within any moment,
if you see somebody locked in their fear,
I encourage you to go and speak to them
and help them through it.
I feel like I was always
taught to just believe
that success is right around the corner.
And I truly feel successful
but there's still so much left to do.
And I think that in not
stopping or thinking that,
"Okay, well, well, that
was great now I'm done."
Just always looking forward
and looking for a new adventure
and staying authentic to who
I am and to what my brand is.
Well, I think that I can relate
to every woman out there.
I have been every size there is.
So, I know how to dress every body type.
I truly believe that it's
not just about high fashion.
We all need pieces in our
wardrobe that are fashionable
but accessible, wearable, and affordable.
I think that that's really
what has made the brand
such a success.
- What were your expectations of yourself?
Did you ever think it could
turn into something like this?
- I had no idea.
I mean, we really just
started out with shoes
and accessories and now
we're going into active wear
and we have maternity and
we're going into home and--
- [Interviewer] Fragrance.
- Hopefully opening stores soon.
So, it's just continuing to
expand and grow everyday.
The team around me, respects
that I give them the credit
and they want to work for me.
They want the line to succeed
because they believe in me.
And so, to surround myself with family
and the people that
work on the collection,
it's just, it's the heart of my business.
And I appreciate each
and every one of them
and I would never ever take the credit.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Robin Nicole's songwriter
asked me to.
So, if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Jessica Simpson's
top 10 rules meant the most to you.
Leave it in the comments
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.